hey everyone I'm Sam Richie I'm so happy
to be back at strange Loop this is my
second time uh I came in 2017 and it's
just nice to be in a group of people of
lispers and functional programmers and
like a crowd where a full house will
come to a talk on computational physics
and lisp stuff like this is not my house
experience when I'm at home so thank you
for this um so who am I uh I started in
the closure functional programming world
back in 2010 I had my mind blown with
the little schemer uh I think many of us
have been through similar experiences
and that's why we're here uh I had a
phase working for big companies doing
big data stuff with Scala uh you know
went through that whole track uh and in
the last few years I've been off in the
Wilds again of lisp working on a
computer algebra system um which we'll
talk a bit about today about why I'm
doing that not many people uh it doesn't
seem to be a common thing to do um but
it's been three years now of of work
that I'd love to share with you and uh
present and and justify a little bit um
so what's happened since 2017 what's
changed in my life uh in the last few
years I've become a dad I have uh three
kids now I have these little twins and
then my four-year-old Juno and as I move
forward with my tech life and my Tech
Career uh these kids have me thinking
about how to share with them the culture
that we have here like there's an
exciting thing that goes on at strange
Loop all of us are really turned on to
this Myriad of wacky ideas that
presenters go over and I'm finding that
it's difficult to imagine how to break
the news to them about how amazing all
this stuff is I mean amar's talk uh at
the beginning of the conference was
really heartening for me because there
are ways through this but the stereotype
at least I have of young math and
physics educat a is there's a bottleneck
you have to go through and not many
people make it through this and come out
the other side able to experience the
beauty and joy that's on the other side
that we've all found so like I didn't
want my kids to smash against the
bottleneck um I find that stories and
music and play are so just natural and
easy to do with my kids and all the time
we're reading and and you know they are
the sources of all of that um these
things can be performed and told you
know stories and heroes are so wonderful
and there's so much material to pull
from um and the culture of math and
physics I find is in many cases trapped
behind this symbolic you know language
which is incredible and lovely once you
get it it's still hard work and it's
it's it's tough to break to someone in a
visual way um so over the past however
many years I've really come to this
feeling that the story of math and
physics and our development with
engineering is one of the great heroic
stories of humanity it's like it's crazy
that you can look out at the world and
write numbers down about what you see
and turn a crank and check the numbers
later and like the world matches what
you see like this is wild that there's
structure here to be predicted um and
the fight to learn that and to figure
out you know how atoms work and what's
at the core and how to go predict how
heat moves is this incredible story that
I think is up there with any of the
great epics uh but that's not I learned
this stuff I learned this stuff by going
through tools and kind of acquiring
things one at a time uh so the culture
is there it's really beautiful it's
stuck behind this symbolic filter um so
I wanted to do something about this I
love building tools uh I guess it's a
classic thing to you know not really
look at the history and just go smash
your head against a problem and make new
stuff um so so I did look to see you
know what is out there what have people
done in the past that gives me
inspiration about passing on culture
that we all love to kids Seymour paper
comes up all the time of course uh who
here's familiar with
logo oh a lot of logo programmers in the
uh in the audience excellent nice um
yeah so th this is seamour paper uh logo
I I'll show a picture of in the next
slide but like this is the floor turtle
that uh I read I read about in
Mindstorms it's this robot that instead
of moving a light around the screen you
have this big clunky thing with a pen on
it and you and your programming language
you can tell this thing to put its pen
up or down move forward turn and here's
a beautiful little fish that was drawn
um programs with this fairly simple core
language you're able to move up to
building you know pictures and art and
these beautiful things pretty quickly
and what I love about reading about logo
is it's introduced to kids with no real
description of what's going on it's like
right you say forward one right two like
to what well it doesn't matter just just
play Just fiddle around and see what
happens happens
and this goes into classrooms kids play
around they realize they can build sort
of beautiful things like this and what
happens is you get stuck you know you're
trying to draw your flower and it's
difficult you your petals are all over
the place like they're kind of it's hard
to pin them at the at the center and in
the ideal case a teacher is able to come
in then and say ah you know let me teach
you about the rule of 360 like as you're
adding two and subtracting one and doing
all this if you make sure that all your
numbers add up to 360 you'll be to go
your turtle's going to point the same
way when when you come back to the start
and so that tool gets grabbed by the
kids and then they can do more
complicated stuff and this idea of
dosing out the the culture of math and
physics as you go in this playful lovely
world is like so appealing to me um
another feature of logo is that it's
very easy for quite young kids to
confuse teachers you can get into states
that don't make any sense or broken or
buggy forcing teachers into this
debugging mode that again we all most of
us are experienced with uh where instead
of a teacher student relationship you
just have people playing and figuring it
out you're forced into this well we're
doing the same thing now relationship
um this is uh Dynamic land uh let me
just see if I can scroll this down
uh so Dynamic land uh some of you may be
familiar with this but this is Brett
Victor's like research project building
out in the West Coast which I still
haven't been to um what dynamic land
does that I really resonated with is it
says look the computer is not a precious
object we're going to turn this entire
building into a Computing infrastructure
and pieces of paper and nonprecious
tokens and things like this will be able
to animate the world and have things
come to life
so one difficulty with talking about
math and physics models is that you want
to talk about things like gravity and
electrical potentials and things don't
really move that way in the real world
or that not the real world the the world
at hand to kids it turns out you can
project things and make them very close
at hand by turning pieces of paper into
things that can bring waterfalls to life
and and things like this so this is very
lovely and um I love this my only
critique of it is it's stuck in this
building out in Oakland like I don't
have this stuff and I I like I want it
for my kids at home um but you know
maybe something to build uh Brett Vic or
this isn't Brett Victor this is Grant
Sanderson does anyone here know the
three blue run Brown videos yeah they're
so good you can Applause for applaud for
Grant if you want
um Grant is like a National Treasure I
mean this stuff is incredible and these
the visual sense you get for math that
really bowled me over in school um is is
astonishing with his stuff uh again like
the critique I the only critique I have
is it's not these are videos that I
can't get my hands on and make my own
things from there are libraries to to
make new videos like this but in some
sense they're they're stuck behind glass
I can't pull them out and play with
them um I'm like up here just critiquing
Brett Victor and Grant Sanderson and
just throwing shade
that's that's that's a good way to start
a talk um The Diamond age so there's
this there's this object yeah now I'm
even getting like further a field
because this is just a madeup thing
right this doesn't even exist but
there's this this this plot device of a
an object inside the book there's a
young girl who gets this thing called
the young ladies Illustrated primer and
the primer is backed by this you know AI
system and set of actors and things like
this and it's able to predict sort of
things she needs in her life at the time
she needs them and guide her from being
a young girl up through this sort of
warrior uh by presenting lessons and um
um tools teachers her to fight things
like this and and this again just always
comes up when as a this this far dream
of uh personalizing education and things
that would really sort of tailor the
let's get past the symbol barrier uh for
for kids and then we have these two
books uh these are unlikely heroes in
the uh in the story um these are two
books by Gerald susman and Jack wisdom
so these are again like we're talking
about stuff for kids and now I have on
the screen these two graduate level
physics
textbooks uh written by Gerald sesman of
Si CP uh and many other sort of
legendary accomplishments and then Jack
wisdom His Brilliant colleague um so
what susman and wisdom did in these
books is they took really the grand
scope of classical mechanics like all
non-quantum physics up through general
relativity and said look the culture
you're trying to communicate is not even
designed for that it's this it's a
culture that's very insular of physics
it's written in math it's very hard to
even read if you don't don't have
someone there walking you through it
what we're going to do is write
everything down in scheme it's going to
be precise if you're confused you can
just run the program and you know there
we go we're going to get clarity through
lisp everything's going to be
wonderful uh I won't read all this but
if anyone's seen this this this is I'll
read the a couple lines last night I
drifted off while reading a list book
suddenly I was bathed in a suffusion of
blue and you know this character wax is
poetic for a while it's the universe is
built of list for what an incredible
realization um and God says that's not
the case it's not I mean ostensibly yes
but we hacked most of it together with
pearl like not good um and reading
numerical code like that's the case you
know if you want to dig into how physics
simulations work or you want to get the
sense of how the universe is built uh
it's not en list but Jerry said yes it
is we're going to do this um and it's
funny the well I'll go into the library
later the builds all this um sort of a
like dry humor like he starts by saying
oh these are the oiler The Grange
equations that govern how physical
systems evolve you know what could this
expression possibly mean this totally
confusing um and his conclusion is that
this is less
confusing which I believed for years is
not that's not the case this is just as
confusing uh you know it's I don't think
he's kidding but um but still there's
there's a gem here of something
incredible which is that unlike many of
the other examples I'd found this is a
library that builds
everything of the physics culture I
wanted to communicate and I started to
think wow like if I could just get this
thing out of the book and into the
browser and attach a visualizer to it
and hook it up to robots that would be
amazing I I could go back and just
rewind from this this later point that
he started me at this grad level
mechanics and I would know that no one
would ever top out working with a system
like this if you had a logo or something
like it driven by this sort of Library
you'd never get to the end of it or if
you did like good for you you know
you're you've now joined the ranks of um
you don't need my help anymore um so the
steps to go about this this project that
I took on
uh it's a little weird if you again you
remember where we started which was
teaching kids but uh you know bear with
me here the steps were I figured first I
need to build a computer algebra system
it needs to be something that can
actually live in a browser because so
many of these things are stuck you know
Mathematica is a beautiful system but
it's an expensive thing it's it's hidden
behind you know corporate boundaries we
don't like that um and so much of the
book again it's lispy and it's lovely
but it's got these static figures and I
can't animate them so I can't see what
all this stuff is talking
about um so build a computer algebra
system do it in a way that leaves kind
of more for other people to steal than I
found when I was beginning this uh and
another critical thing from my closure
and closure script days I knew that if I
went to a lisp like closure that
anything I the thing I built could run
in all these different environments I
could go plug it back in as a set of
batteries into something like what's
powering Dynamic land or the logo in
these Turtles um and then the last two
so this is three is where we're at now
uh the last two are um are are what
comes next I think that tools like this
that aren't collaborative are are very
very difficult to uh become these
Community catalyzing things um so we'll
talk about those next steps as we move
on um and the current state is that I
well I'll show
you let's see if this
loads
this will be a wild punch line if this
doesn't
load here let's
see okay here we
go okay I'll kind of scroll this
uh yeah so we're going to see some more
interactive stuff later but basically we
we have uh this computer algebra system
now which is embedded in a notebook this
is all written in closure uh and this is
derived from a closure source file um
I'll show you versions in a minute that
are editable as well all of this is able
to run completely in the browser um but
you know you're not meant to understand
this as we go but just as we scroll see
this is a series of sort of test cases
we've
got we've got a blank
screen
well let's wait for this to load so what
we'll see is we've got a bunch of Lis
code that's able to whenever this
unpackaged thing loads uh generate a
bunch of math and then it's also able to
power these simulations here so this
here is a Taurus uh this was summoned
into existence using the function that I
wrote above and if I can reach up here
and again I'll show more of these soon
but this has these interactive Sliders
in it so uh this code is able to um
build these sort of very fast JavaScript
functions from symbolic descriptions
above and uh do all of this live in the
browser uh I'll scroll down and you know
we can run these sort of wild beautiful
simulations that usually you'd have to
descend down to JavaScript and write
really really difficult to read stuff
that's not high level um the code that's
able to make this uh again we'll look at
some better examples shortly but the
code that's able to make this is very
high level and able to be kind of pulled
apart and recombined in different ways
uh so that little
preview let me make this a full screen
again so the library that powers all
this stuff uh that that we'll get into
is called scheme utils and I always
chuckled that like this is kind of a bad
name for a library but Jerry's able to
do that because he wrote scheme and his
utilities for scheme Implement general
relativity
um uh this is one of the tests in the
library ported to closure you'll notice
it's called the Einstein field equations
test uh it takes a while to run but this
does run when the uh the test Suite uh
kicks off it's very important to check
that these haven't
changed it's just sort of nuts right
like people who build physics
simulations don't go this far this is
sort of pathological
Behavior
um but we can steal that right like we
can steal this stuff uh and and plug it
into other systems that are a bit more
friendly um so the system is built on
this principle you know again sort of
dry humor from Jerry if A System's built
as a ball of mud it's easy to add more
mud and then you know one organization
is a system erected on a substrate of
generically extensible procedures it's
like if you want to play you need to be
able to slap stuff on and have other
people contribute to what you've built
so I totally buy the first sentence
um the system is built on this very
simple core this algebra system starts
by taking all of the math operators
enclosure and swapping them out for
these generically extensible procedures
um so scheme utils I should say about it
it's this 65 or 70,000 line like monster
of a computer algebra system that he
started in the late 80s uh I think Jerry
was on sabatical like teaching physics
with Richard feeman out at Caltech and
working on like numerical General
relativity stuff and started this scheme
utils project and he's just been hacking
on it and he leaves a copy on his server
and the students download it and it's
this total sleeper um but again like
there to be
taken so uh it's built on this very
simple core of take the math operations
swap them out for generically extensible
stuff and then Implement a bunch of data
types that know how to talk to things
like Plus or cross product or dot
product so you start with basic numbers
you extend it with symbols complex
numbers vectors things like this um and
then we can do calculus I won't go into
how but by uh extending again to a
different numerical type called a dual
number uh and again like this
implementation goes so it goes deeper
into this stuff than all the you know
machine learning stuff out there now um
like you can differentiate higher order
functions that return other functions
and just totally nuts um but all these
things start to play together so with a
pretty small core you can do things like
you know here we have I'm
differentiating the square of a vector
of
functions uh like why would you do this
you probably wouldn't you just want to
make a tight slide to sort of freak
people out um but that creates a new
function that when it receives its
arguments will make a vector adding them
and multiplying them and then you'll
square that so you'll take the dot
product of the Vector with itself and
that operation you take the derivative
of and you know then you pass it into a
simplifier and you end up with this very
very tight code which doesn't make for
nice reading when you're just staring at
symbols but as we'll see later does make
for very high performance
visualizations um just another example
of nested functions we have you know a
function that takes an angle and gives
you back the X and y-coordinates of a
vector on a unit circle uh then I want
the magnitude of that thing just out of
the box that would be kind of a
nightmare it turns out it simplifies
down to zero and there's a very nice
simplifier here too that we can we can
uh hook on to um another thing I stuck
to that was a little over the top for
this is uh this idea of code is
Literature Like I became quite
frustrated reading numerical code uh
implementing this all of it is this very
tur for trand kind of copy pasted over
the over the years uh it's it's nonsense
like this is not how you communicate a
culture if anyone Works in numeric
programming please don't do this like
and you'll see in the next slide how I
come down on the comments versus no
comments uh debate um this really stuck
with me from sicp um I took it maybe too
seriously uh so the library is built
like this like this is one of the this
is the namespace that implements
automatic differentiation exported as a
notebook using the system itself um so
it really kind of goes pretty crazy on
justifying all this stuff um but the
thought was that you know if you have
like as you read this textbook about
physics you hitting all of these
Crossroads of numerical Computing and
other sort of wonderful topics that just
don't get covered they're in footnotes
saying worry about that later worry
about that later um the culture is
really sort of everything is tied
together and networked and you know a
really A system that is really there to
be explored you should be able to
hyperlink and jump around um and not be
sort of let down by tur 4 train code um
final thing missing was uh a set of
visualizations so I went out and I found
this Library called
mathbox uh mathbox was written by this
mad genius named Steven wittens um he
built this incredible declarative system
for doing mathematical visualizations um
all this stuff can be interacted with uh
I can't really reach these sliders up
here but oh yeah look at that you can
mess with these things so it's all fast
and incredible and beautiful but when
you read the code to make this you don't
really have any idea what's going on
like he sort of pre-compiled down this
numerical code to run these things um
and so again like this sense of all the
beautiful stuff is just stuck behind
glass and you can't get your hands on it
was really present for
me
so let's let this load
sorry for the slow internet
everyone here let's try
this I'm going to switch
to
[Music]
all
right all right this is totally worth
looking at so let me see if I can pull
this up a different way
[Music]
uh look at this live coding going
on okay here we
go it was cooler when this was embedded
in the slide
um okay so here where this all ends up
is that what we have now is a computer
algebra system plus a visualization
system that's able to run totally in the
browser and is interactive in a way that
I'll show now where visualizations
become first class objects that you can
mess around with sort of playfully
create and share uh so here we have
let's see I can zoom in on this probably
here we have a line saying I want a
function of x uh it's going to all I
need to sign here color blue that goes
ahead and plots I can start
uh coding against
this and changing things and things just
go kind of live update on the side as I
go uh let's
see
um I've got calculus I've got
derivatives um this is not a normal
thing to have happen in a browser like
the entire system is running in the
browser and if I go ahead and send this
link to anyone here they now have the
entire algebra system too this is
compiled as a static JavaScript bundle
and the code on the left is getting
interpreted and run through all of the
computer algebra stuff you need and then
anything that goes off to the visualizer
is compiled down to a fast JavaScript
function so any animations that we'll
see later are sort of smoking fast uh
but the object that powers all this
stuff is just a static data structure
it's sort of server side rendering for
Math and physics um so these things
compos nicely we've got a visualization
at the top here we've got a scene that
is built out of two plots and again like
no problem I can just comment one out
all the stuff is happening live um
here's one this a little better this is
an interactive
scene uh so this is sort of multiple
functions that if you wrote out the
numerical code for them is is it's tough
to do the it's tough to do the cube uh
the third derivative of a hyperbolic
tangent let me tell
you um but yeah all this stuff like
JavaScript is so good now and and to
have a declarative system for building
visualizations like you can sort of see
these demos as just proof of concept for
it it's fairly nuts to be able to put
stuff together like this that are just
bags of you know function Point hook it
all together State F get everything to
reactively respond um and things like
these Vector Fields become very natural
compositions where the vector field
itself is built out of a bunch of arrows
and everything is just talking through
closures uh atom data structure um so if
you want you can have multiple
visualizations that are responding to
the same stuff or link these over a
network and have uh one person driving
and a visualization
updating
um uh so here's another one that was a a
2d visualization system uh here's here's
3D that's where we'll stop
um but we've got again like just the
ability to write down uh things with no
care in the world for performance at a
very high level to say I'm just going to
you I'm going to duplicate stuff I'm
going to take sign a bunch of times I'm
going to use like crazy functions and
just kind of see what happens and have
the system respond is really fun and
playful um here's an example here of a a
strange attractor so this we've got the
uh you know the Lorent equations these
are equations that relate coordinates to
how the coordinates are changing of a
point in time so given the XYZ
coordinates I'll tell you what the
speeds are um and then the system is
able to take that and basically Play the
movie Forward uh so here we've got this
wacky line if I go ahead and mess with
these sliders like the line goes ahead
and every time the slider moves the
simulation is rerunning in the browser
for sort of I think 5,000 steps at a
time right now we can crank that up a
little bit
um and this becomes like what I'm
starting to see here as I wrote demos
like this and I I was getting hijacked
like during talk prep because this
stuff's so fun to make is you get into
these zones of like okay I I I've seen
the really cherry-picked coordinates
from papers I've seen this stuff but
being able to just reach in and like
mess with it and sort of find
interesting behaviors uh like this and
then to go up and see the you know the
numbers that made that like you now have
this new way to interact with the system
it's still on a machine it's still
behind glass but like this stuff can run
anywhere and there's no reason you can't
drive it from you know uh get this stuff
out of this kind of
demo um of course we have another Vector
field here's the 3D one that's pretty
nuts oh look all the arrows move those
just so fast it's so
cool um okay so assuming that these
slides are going to fail me um this
geodesics example I showed before uh we
can look at this
again and oh yeah look at that um here's
a version of that again like I'm I sort
of chuckle because I get that this is
not like it's still confusing right like
you still have this I will Jerry hosed
me here a little bit I will say because
the book starts it's such an advanced
level that any demo I give of this like
I come across as this sort of obsessed
with Advanced mechanic
um and uh you know this like look how
easy this is it's so beautiful it
doesn't land quite right with what we're
seeing on the screen um so there's a
future project to sort of pull the level
back but I mean look at like it just
it's so obvious that this is a better
way when you encounter equations that
can go generate a simulation like this
this is so what a geodesic is is if I
have a shape and I have a particle and I
fire it straight line in this room means
like straight line you know that we're
all familiar with but straight line on a
curved surface doesn't look so obvious
like on a sphere you have a great circle
on other shapes and other manifolds
things get a little strange so here we
have a particle let's say here it starts
here it fires forward and I have sliders
that can control the angle that it
starts at and then the angle that it
sort of fires forward on um so as I sort
of mess with this you see again this
like live updating line is very
beautiful um but also lets me explore
these different kinds of harmonics that
this system gets into so the paper will
talk about you know you'll get like I I
sort of thought that the particle would
just coil around the doughnut it turns
out it has all these funky resonances
and uh you know as you adjust the shape
of the um of the donut like look you can
kind of get it big enough that it
crosses itself in the middle um and then
Force the line to sort of go inside and
this is called a a lemon Taurus I
believe like on the uh the inside when
you get a Taurus to intersect itself but
again this is just like a bender I went
off on reading about this stuff from
things I found messing around with the
visualization it was very easy to
confuse like I got to a point where I
had the logo experience of confusing
susman who didn't understand at first
like why this thing wasn't able to
escape when you pointed up near the top
and we figured it out but again just
like this confusing the teacher
confusing the teacher so good
so good um and again all this stuff
is let's show on the next
one oh yeah I kind of went mad with this
during talk prep like I just want to
show these because it's so wild I I just
started going to Wikipedia and like
finding equations for other crazy
surfaces uh and firing geodesics along
them and like I'm just firing geodesics
like left and right I have no idea what
any of this means um but you know we've
got a Klein Bagel here uh uh it's a
technical term please don't use it
uh except with the utmost seriousness I
can do the same thing you know that like
it's not not quite as beautiful I can
unroll this thing um and again like I'll
share these links afterward and you can
see that the stuff to do this is not
hidden behind glass these are just
functions that are building up those
little pieces of the puzzle and because
everything's declarative all you have to
do is change you know the number of
degrees that you want to rotate around
and hook it up to the slider and like
you get these incredible ability to just
sort of mess with stuff in play um and
then send this to other people with the
numbers you found and they can pick up
where you left off um here's a Klein
bottle does anyone have a Klein bottle
here a few nice it turns out there's a
lot of literature around how to write
down the equations for a Klein bottle
that looks pretty like you'd expect like
this this kind of weird right this is
the 3D the um higher dimensional version
of a a Mobius strip and it looks like
it's kind of fiddly and skinny and this
really bothers mathematicians and I
found a paper talking about like how to
make more beautiful ones and they said
there's there's much research left to be
done like we we're very unhappy with the
current state of
things so one of you could
be uh just a final one here we have this
animating thing uh this is actually a
problem from the book um the problem
says you have a an
ellipsoid uh that has a particle on it
and the goal is to find the equations of
motion for this and the solution to the
exercise is this it's
this I'm going I'm going I'm going like
that's it and it's not a joke you get to
the end I I think what he's doing though
is sort of throwing in your face how
annoying this would be to do by hand but
the punch line that it's easier to do on
the computer is not doesn't land for me
right like it's still rough um but if
you hook this thing up to oh gosh let's
see I think I'm scrolling sideways by
accident on my slides um if you hook
this thing up to a visualizer you'll see
like okay does this look normal is this
what you would expect a ball attached to
a crazy ellipse that you can sort of
wiggle and mess with to do um yeah
totally uh and then you can go in and
say well you know what if we change like
cosine here to uh you know like I don't
know hyperbolic sign like what would
that look like and you just option enter
and like whoa this is actually pretty
nuts I don't think I've done this before
um and then you know on the top if I do
this let's try this one oh boy okay so
now we've got this crazy surface and
let's see what
happens and we're
gone oh and numerical instability like
okay this is getting a little wild um
bring me back bring me back
but I I just love like the playfulness
of go mess around go find out and then
not you know figure out what you found
like what happened is such a beautiful
way to mess around with all this stuff
and then the final one I'll show is this
um this was just such a mindblower for
me this is you know we start with these
pretty simple equations of motion of a
pendulum rocking back and forth and the
system Jerry had once you plug it into a
visualizer is able to take uh let just
check the time is able to take uh those
equations of motion and generate like a
workbench of all these beautiful things
like here we have the
pendulum uh here we have the phase
portrait so this is the on the x- axis
we have the angle of the pendulum and
then on the y- axis we have the angular
velocity of the pendulum how fast it's
moving and so the dot in that space your
simple pendulum turns out to have this
beautiful structure that almost looks
like fluid flow um and as I mess with
these sliders and I change the gravity
you can see that all these things change
like these are all independent physics
simulations running uh each of these
lines um and you know I I can sort of
look at either the pendulum or this and
I can make this bead get trapped in
different parts of this fluid
flow
um and you know this is the story that
these these books are trying to tell
this story of really really beautiful
stuff uh that
um if you could only simulate it in your
mind like has this incredible character
to it um okay so what's next
um as I built this stuff this this the
sense I was trying to go for was that I
was trying to like all the things Jerry
has built are almost like a nurse log in
a forest you know he's got the computer
algebra system starts at the very very
bottom like lisp as the the foundation
of the universe and builds up everything
on top of it uh so this is a story that
really you know needs to be out there
and deserves to get told um
so I started to see these as again like
the batteries for these other systems
that were so inspiring uh let's see what
this one is um
so the most obvious next step for me is
to write the prequel to these books like
I think the journey here is to connect
everything that powers this algebra
system and all of the existing
literature with you know first second
third fourth grade like where does
everything begin what does it even mean
to model the world um so one thing is
like the prequel to this this story I've
started writing uh as a series of essays
um that I'll share in the talk slides
when they go out um another thing the
the sort of final step for this though
is that because this is all in
JavaScript and can run in all these
different environments uh the next phase
is to get these out I think into the
world into robots into environments like
this that are more like where kids want
to be and where you know my kids are
going to go be experiencing
all the other sort of beautiful cultural
Transmissions that are out there
um final step is uh I think the final
home for all this ideally would be
something like an intelligent textbook
like the culture that we want to share
is so human-based and so important but
like we live in this world of amazing
tools that can organize and walk you
through this stuff and as people develop
their own sort of loves and different
goals um the ability to have something
like a large language model or something
like this walking you through material
and generating examples and really using
the computational tools that are here to
build your own personal journey is
amazing um that's what I'm doing now I
have this we hiring thing I I just
joined a lab at a MIT that is really
sponsoring a lot of this work and uh the
goal is to go extend this out um if this
is something you'd like to talk about or
work on you know I'm totally open and
we're hiring so um yeah that's it thanks
everyone
[Applause]